hello everyone in this video I'm going
to discuss some points which I believe
will help parents to understand better
the difficulties which their colleg
goinging children face as they're
involved in various kinds of academic as
well as non-academic activities in
college so students if you're watching
this great please um watch this please
continue to watch this I'm sure you are
going to get some useful points out of
it but I request you to please share
this video with your parents also
because is really meant for them I've
made all the points for the sake of your
parents so parents greetings and
namaskar to all of you the first point
which I want to highlight is that
despite what many of uh the people may
be saying I personally believe that it
is extremely important for you to remain
involved in your children's activities I
do not mean to be uh mean for you to be
a helicopter parent not that you don't
have to be involved in a on a absolutely
day-to-day basis not be uh be dictating
to them on a day-to-day basis what they
should be doing or not doing that is
certainly not going to help them really
but I want you to remain aware of the
overall Arc of the things that they are
actually involved in uh please try to
stay updated with their academic
performance because uh I have seen in
many cases that parents are not at all
aware even aware of what their children
are going through which um uh exams are
going on what kind of assignments they
are being given uh you don't have to
micromanage this but at least be aware
of the kinds of things that they are
going through this is extremely
extremely important in my personal
opinion uh I'm afraid that some uh
parents almost take a sense of pride in
uh saying that they are giving a
complete free reign to their students uh
see
I am all up for this kind of a modern
upbringing where you do give some free
rign to your students give appropriate
space to your children that is all fine
but it giving space in my personal
opinion does not mean that uh you remain
absolutely unaware of what is going on
taking stock And discussing with your
children about their progress about
their hopes and aspirations does not
mean helicopter parenting at all so
please do this and it's a little
unfortunate that uh quite a few of the
uh parents who remain unaware of their
children's progress or even if they are
progressing or not uh ultimately when
something uh bad happens regarding their
progress uh sometimes they are getting
too many backlogs in their uh subjects
this uh students it is then and only
then that the parents wake up this is
rather unfortunate
it is then that they come to the faculty
advisers meet the professors uh request
them for uh help so when things just
start to go wrong if at that very point
in the neck of time if parents step in
and try to help the students I think
that would be a more appropriate way of
tackling the difficulties rather than
coming in when things have already
become very very wrong
so this is my request to all of you that
Please be aware and stay in the
loop the next point is that um as
parents you have to understand uh very
importantly the the absolute differences
in the education of your children during
the J days and after J when they have
actually joined the Institute because
see before J the it is quite obvious
actually before J
the students had a very very clear-cut
goal before them they have to crack J
that's
it but after J when they have joined a
college there is no such laser focus in
front of
them so instead of that they have a
variety of options to set their target
from now that can be extremely exciting
but at the same time very very confusing
they have so many options in front of
them for example they can choose to
prepare for higher studies they can uh
choose to prepare for maybe civil
services which many students do they can
choose to go for some kind of
co-curricular activities like
competitive programming or some kind of
uh other uh activities which are uh not
just not exactly extracurricular but
side by side with their academics but
not really within the syllabus also or
at the very extreme they can be very
much interested in something completely
extracurricular like singing dancing
Sports whatever you name it okay so all
sorts of opportunities all sorts of uh
options are there in college uh and this
is across the various good Institutes of
India so when they are faced with this
overwhelming uh platter of options and
possibilities it is extremely extremely
likely that they are feeling overwhelmed
and completely at a loss of what to
do now what can you do well first of all
you have to first of all understand that
they are going through this this kind of
a confusing thing and you have to be on
their team so professors cannot really
help here so you cannot be their coach
but you have to be like a silent member
in their team silent means non-playing
member okay not silent you have to be
vocal but uh you have to be uh you have
to make them feel that you are on their
side and you are helping them navigate
this confusing
Waters so uh I need not highlight this
you know very well that in real life
which is adult
life uh life is full of uncertainities
full of vagueness there is nobody to
tell us which options are the best for
us to go
ahead this we all realize in our adult
life but when your children are just
growing up in this very tender uh uh
juncture of
life I think even if you have not gone
through an engineering College yourself
you are experienced in real life so try
to give them the benefit of your
experiences from real life regarding
these uncertainities tell them that that
it is absolutely okay to be uncertain to
be confused there is nothing wrong in
being confused it does not mean that
they are failing at life okay this is
the the natural order of things being
confused being uncertain at this stage
of life in fact I would say this
uncertainty is very much a part and
parcel of life even if one grows much
older too so please try to inculcate in
them an appreciation for this
uncertainty it is all right okay I think
they need to hear from you much more
they need to hear from us professors
that it is all right to be uncertain it
is all right to be
confused next point is that uh on top of
all of this confusion the education
system in the actual institutes uh is
quite different from what is followed in
the coaching institutes the coaching
institutes by necessity have uh tuned
their education system their teaching
okay so I'll not call this real teaching
so that's where the air quods their
teaching is uh is tuned is very much
fine-tuned over and over the years uh of
their business
Endeavor to cater to the sole purpose of
the J or neat or whatever so to the sole
purpose of cracking the exam so their
way of teaching things is a very
regimented fashion and when students are
are trained through this kind of a
course uh of regimented training they
become accustomed to a certain way of
learning things which I'm sure if you
have not gone through a coaching
Institute yourself and you have been
like uh I mean you have grown up as part
of the classical traditions of teaching
and learning you'll appreciate it very
much that this is not really how it is
uh how it should be okay real education
is not like that but it is what it is a
necessary evil our coaching institutes
so when students your children have gone
through this process for 2 3 years 4
years maybe even uh for higher number of
years they feel a
serious difficulty in adjusting to the
to the real system of Education which we
actually follow in our institutes so
here what we do as you might be already
uh aware is that we professors we just
present the study material in front of
the students we come to class we teach
and we give them the reference materials
the teaching materials and we expect
them to take it up or not take it up
based on their own responsibility and
that's that okay this is how it actually
works in any University system or any
Institute system all across the world so
ultimately it all boils down to the
students own responsibility there is no
regimented course here no Professor is
going to go after the students to tell
them what to do on a day-to-day basis
sure we have the system of assignments
sure we have the system of very
demanding examinations and so on and so
forth But ultimately for the when it
comes to the actual preparation we do
not chart out anything for the students
to follow on a day-to-day
basis so it is up to the students uh to
take it up to to do it or not do it so
when they are suddenly given this kind
of a free reign um it certainly becomes
confusing but more
importantly uh they are just not
accustomed okay they have not been
trained to to study like this so no
matter how how much we professors say it
because see they they are coming from
the coaching Institute teachers to the
to the teaching of the professors and
because they are more familiar with that
probably they have a little bit of a
trust issue with what we professors uh
are doing sometimes they even feeling
that uh we are not good enough teachers
that's a different issue altogether
whether we are good or not I've have
addressed that in a separate video but
uh be that as it may I think it'll be
really helpful if you uh discuss this
with your children that this is what uh
I mean taking responsibility for oneself
and picking up what you need to do uh
that is what is I mean very much a part
and parcel of being an adult okay so
just like in real life you all know this
uh you have to be self-driven self
motivated to complete your own things so
also in college life which is just a
training ground for adult life uh which
is very much to start after college uh
and probably even from college uh they
have to start doing this this okay so
when they are facing this difficulty uh
please try to understand the context of
this difficulty this is my this is the
point that I want to highlight please do
not get angry with them if their
academic performance starts to fall
because uh please don't mind me saying
this is it not true that you yourself
sent your kids to the coaching
institutes so it is not their fault that
they got more accustomed to that way of
teaching okay so just pause and think
about it for a second suddenly overnight
if you if you expect them to change
their their expectations of the teaching
and learning environment to what is
there in the college that is not going
to happen this is especially true for
students and parents of the first year
I'll leave it at that the next point
that I want to highlight is uh see after
coming to college students do get a lot
of free reign they uh start start
growing up and they their their minds um
it starts uh blossoming in different
directions uh all this while they were
like like a race horse preparing for J
preparing for neat uh they had that Big
Shiny Target in front of them but now
that is all gone and the options are
there in front of them they do sometimes
pick up completely different kinds of
options uh for example
they might be interested in something
completely extracurricular so uh in this
kind of a scenario it is uh it is
expected that you will feel a little bit
nervous about their choices uh when they
start neglecting their academics but uh
please do not take an antagonistic stand
by default when this kind of a thing
happens or if this kind of a thing
happens uh rather try to understand the
motivation behind uh this kind of of a
choice that your children are trying to
make try to discuss with them uh what is
their plan about handling their academic
side by side
because uh one thing is true that even
if they are getting very much interested
in the extracurricular activities they
ultimately have to complete their degree
okay so you have to discuss this with
them what is their plan and instead of
like blur getting out your anger or your
apprehensions uh or projecting your
apprehensions on them uh if you maybe
just take a take a step back and discuss
with them uh trying to understand what
is going on through their minds maybe
it'll actually help them to see that you
are not like an enemy okay because they
always think professors are the enemy so
they have to have a friend on them their
side okay so I cannot emphasize this
enough you have again I'm saying this
you have to be like a team member so you
have to make them feel that you are
there to uh support them at the back end
okay
uh so if this kind of a thing happens
then I'm sure uh students will be able
to handle their academics side by side
with their extra regular things to a
much better extent compared to a
situation where their parents you force
them to completely give up on this new
found aspiration of theirs to devote a
considerable amount of time on the
extracurricular activity and to focus
solely on the
academics which you may be thinking U
they should be doing so uh
if you force like that no good will come
of it there are ample examples of it
maybe they will give up on their
extracurricular activities but as they
say you can bring a horse to the water
but you cannot make him drink it so even
if they're going to class even if they
are not doing anything other than their
academics their hurt may not be it and
they may not be actually be able to do
as well as if they are given some
freedom to pursue their extracurricular
things and do their academic side by
side so if you're like a friend to them
they're like a team member who is
helping them navigate uh these kinds of
uh uh two-pronged approach to their uh
to their progress in life so to speak I
think uh it'll be a tremendous
tremendous boost to
them so uh with these points I think I
have covered very broadly the kind of
things which uh I have found sometimes
lacking in the relationship between the
parents and the students because there
is always the problem of the uh the lack
of geographical
proximity uh so when the parents are not
here in the campus there is always a
disconnect so I again reiterate this
please try to have um some kind of an
involvement have some kind of an
awareness of what the students are going
through this is especially especially
important in first year when students
are utterly utterly confused uh even if
they are performing well okay so just
because your students are doing well
academically it does not necessarily
mean that everything is well and
fine it is fine certainly compared to
maybe others but there may be still some
things wrong uh there are a lot of other
aspects on the personal front which
students um get exposed to uh I'm sure
as parents you are uh mature enough to
understand what I'm alluding to here and
maybe that is the topic of another long
discussion but uh there is nobody else
in the world who can uh help your
children better than you yourself okay
so on on this note uh I I really hope
that you will take my uh discussion of
these points on a positive note and uh
you will try to understand the
difficulties the context of the
difficulties which your students which
your children are going through and
you'll be able to help them okay so on
this note uh namaskar again thank you
very much and all the best to you your
family and your children thank you